all right good afternoon i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this afternoon to brief you
on a homicide investigation
that we are conducting in the 20 i'm
sorry the 4700 block of copper sage
street which is which is a commercial
area
near the intersections of lamb and craig
i stress the details that i'm sharing
right now are very preliminary and i
apologize but it is going to be
extremely convoluted to explain so
at around 11 o'clock this morning
officers responded on report of a
shooting in the
street directly behind me what we have
learned
is that a group of co-workers that
work at a business directly behind me
were involved in an
altercation specifically and i'll refer
to them as employees
one in two employees one and two
were involved in an altercation earlier
this morning
those two employees had agreed to have a
fist fight
after or at lunch time so
at lunchtime employees one and two walk
off of the property
down the street to fight several other
of the employees
followed them from the business to watch
the fight
employee number two also called a friend
of his
to witness the fight one during the
fight
was winning the fight with employee
number two
at that point the friend that employee
number two called
pulled out a handgun and started
shooting
as a result of him shooting he struck
employees
number three and four who were
witnessing the fight
and also struck the person who was
winning the fight
everybody then fled the scene with the
exception of employee number
three who was witness who was watching
the fight
employee number three is a hispanic male
who was transported to umc trauma where
he was pronounced deceased
moments later we received a call from
north vista hospital
that another male had been dropped off
that male
is going to be employee number four who
is a hispanic male in his late teens
he was then transported from north vista
hospital to umc trauma
he is currently in critical condition at
umc trauma
while officers were on scene we were
notified that another
male had contacted north las vegas
police advising that he had been
shot that male was employee number two
who was the person struck during the
gunfire when he was involved in
i'm sorry employee number one who was
involved in the fight with employee
number two
so right now we are looking for the
friend of employee number two
and employee number two who fled the
scene they are all described as hispanic
males
in their late teens to early twenties we
do
know who employee number two is we just
don't know who his friend is that's
where we're at at this point in the
investigation
so just to recap we have one person
deceased
who is a hispanic male in his early 20s
we have two
other victims both of gunshot wounds one
in critical condition
the other with described as
non-life-threatening
uh injuries i urge anyone who has any
information to please reach out to crime
stoppers your information can
will be completely anonymous or you can
also reach out to homicide
lvmpd.com and and again
urge anybody who has any information to
please reach out to us with that i'll
take a couple questions if you have them
commission on employee number one and an
employee number two
facing any possible charges in this
right now it's still too early on in the
investigation regarding employee number
two
we don't know we're still trying to find
out what exactly led up to the shooting
as far as employee your question with
number one was
condition his injuries are described as
non-life threatening he has a gunshot
wound but non-life threatening
do we know if employee number two called
his friend with the purpose of bringing
a gun
we know he called his friend we don't
know what the purpose of that
conversation was that's what we're still
trying to figure out
we know that employee number two was
losing the fist fight and that's what
prompted his friend to pull out a gun
and start shooting
can you tell us what business and did
their supervisors know that they had
planned some
sort of fight and happened no i don't
think
i'm not going to put out the name of the
business that they're involved in or
with there's nothing at this point that
leads us to believe that the supervisors
knew that is why they left the
property of the business trying to keep
it away from the
actual business that they worked at did
other employees tell you the information
about the fight the plan or is that one
of the victims
it's i'm not going to get into the
specifics of how we got to the
preliminary information that i'm
disclosing but that's kind of where
we're at at this point
this this just seems really childish how
this started i mean the kind of
playground stuff that you hear about in
high school
can you give me some sort of context
here how rare is this
to happen at a business park have you
been on a call like this before
it's it's a unique situation where you
have people that are working together
that
leads to a fist fight where people show
up and start shooting
this is unique are you getting a lot of
cooperation or people being
tight-lipped you said that there were a
lot of witnesses a lot of people were
involved are they
helping there's a lot of people at the
scene cooperating with the investigation
it's just it's extremely complex kind of
just trying to
explain it let alone you know put all
the moving parts together so to come
together throughout the afternoon
and i'm sure we'll have more later in
the evening you know what led up to the
fight
i don't know what led up to the fight i
i've gotten some information that
they've had an ongoing dispute between
the two of them as far as employees
wanting to
right but that's something management
was unaware of as far as you know i
don't know the specifics of what
management knows i just know that's the
information that we're getting
all right thank you guys appreciate it
thanks